il y a il y a des moments
clés histori dans la vie d'un mouvement
politique le 30 mai ce 30 mai sera l'un
de ces moments un moment de mobilisation
bien évidemment un moment d'enthousiasme
et d'engagement mais aussi avant tout un
moment
d'unité l'unité qui est si essentielle
pour redonner confiance et pour
travailler ensemble unité pour laquelle
je veux vre non remercier Nicolas car je
sais combien il est attaché à cette
unité et l'énergie qu'il déploie pour
garantir l'unité de notre famille
politique mais pourquoi l'unité serait
plus facile aujourd'hui mais tout
simplement parce que vous êtes là mes
amis vous êtes des milliers et c'est
vous qui êtes les vrais garants de
l'unité de notre famille politique et je
veux en profiter ici à cette tribune
pour adresser un message
un message à tous les dirigeants de
notre mouvement qui ont été ou qui
seront à ma place pour le dire la chose
suivante vous qui parlez à cette tribune
dans les réseaux sociaux mais vous qui
parlez aussi dans le poste le poste de
télévision le poste de radio ou qui
parlait dans les journaux quand parfois
l'envie vous vient de faire une
déclaration ton truante sur l' d'hier ou
sur les républicains
aujourd'hui au mémoire le visage de tous
ces militants qui sont ici présents à la
Villette regardez bien leur sourire
quand il sourit c'est parce qu'ils nous
savent concentrer sur notre mission et
avec l'esprit d'équipe le sourire des
militants des républicain ce matin il
est 1000 fois plus important que le
sourire des journalistes qui sont face à
vous et avec le petit sourire qui sera
le leure quand vous aurez prononcé la
petite phrase qui fait tant de
mal leur sourire est plus important
par que c'est le sourire des Français
qui sont heureux quand les politiques se
consacrent à eux et pas seulement au
microc parce que la fameuse petite
phrase prononcée au dépend de l'unité
cette phrase elle fera le buzz le buzz
médiatique elle fera le bu politique
cette petite phrase elle sera reprise
mais elle nous fragilise et en résumé il
y a beaucoup à dire dans les médias sur
nos idées sur nos convictions et si
l'envie de critiquer est si forte il y a
beaucoup
sur nos seuls adversaires politiques il
y a à dire sur le Parti socialiste dont
les Français ne veulent
plus il y a à dire sur le front national
dont les Français ne veulent pas un
parti socialiste qui a menti sur le
chômage et les impôts qui a trahi le
peuple français et qui fait tant de mal
à la France et au français un Front
National qui confond famille politique
et clan
familial un parti qui n'est pas comme
les autres c'est vrai vra c'est un parti
avec des dirigeants pires que les autres
avec des dirigeants sans scrupule qui
veulent le pouvoir pour eux-mêmes et pas
pour les Français un parti incapable
d'apporter une seule solution au
problème de la France et des Français
alors oui il y a tant à dire pour parler
éducation comme cela a été fait à
l'instant cette valeur tant mal menée
par le Parti socialiste et les
idéologues mais nous pouvons aussi
parler d'une valeur centrale pour la
société française celle qui était au
cœur not engement
2007 celle à laquelle je crois plus que
tout valeur qui n'est ni de droite ni de
gauche valeur méprisé par le Front
National et valeur maltraité par le
Parti socialiste valeur porté par l'UMP
par les républicains demain mes amis je
veux vous parler de la valeur travail de
la valeur du
[Applaudissements]
travail VUR
trava ité à la fraternité la valeur
travail c'est la seule façon de créer
les richesses dont notre pays a besoin
de redonner dignité et reconnaissance à
chacun la valeur travail depuis le
général de Gaulle elle est au cœur de
notre sensibilité et notre engagement
elle mérite des réformes fortes plus que
des mots des réformes qui peuvent
déplaire des réformes qui dépasseront le
confort des intérêts particuliers pour
servir le seul intérêt qui vaille
l'intérêt général
national et je dis d'ailleurs prenons
garde prenons bien garde même chez nous
au pouvoir anesthésiant du retour de la
croissance la croissance ne règlera pas
comme par miracle notre retard
économique elle ne suffira pas car il
nous faudra mener des réformes
ambitieuses plus ambitieuses avec des
solutions nouvelles et un vrai courage
un courage débarrassé des sondages un
courage débarrassé de la peur de
déplaire pour conduire les réformes
jusqu'au bout vraiment jusqu'au
bout cela veut dire aussi faire des
choix et les assumer devant vous je fais
le choix d'agir pour ceux qui
travaillent permettre de vivre de son
travail sans leur faire les poches avec
un matraquage fiscal sans précédent leur
permettre d'augmenter leur pouvoir
d'achat en rétablissant je l'assume les
heures supplémentaires défiscalisées qui
redonnaient du sens à la valeur
travail avec une TVA sociale qui en
taxant les importations permet de
baisser les chargge des salariés et de
rapprocher le salaire net du salaire
brut et donc d'augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat et c'est aussi faire le choix du
principe républicain d'égalité d'égalité
entre le public et entre le privé
demain nous aurons être courageux et il
ne s'agira pas seulement de remettre un
jour de le public parce que les
socialistes l'ont enlevé non s'il y a 3
jours de carence dans le privé c'est 3
jours de carence dans le public voilà ce
que c'est l'égalité
républicaine et pour les retraites c'est
pareil si les primes doivent être prises
en charge nous ne pouvons pas d'un côté
avoir les 25 meilleures années pour
calculer sa retraite dans le privé et
avoir les 6 derniers mois dans le public
ce sont les mêmes règles les républicain
pousse l'égalité
républicaine
alors on me dit Xavier tu ne devrais pas
parler de ça parce que tu es candidat
aux élections régionales et ce que tu
dis pourrait dé plaire je pense qu'à
force de chercher à plaire à tout le
monde à force d'avoir peur de déplaire à
chacun on finira par N tourner le dos
voilà pourquoi il faut assumer nos
convictions et nos
positions cela veut dire aussi aider
ceux qui veulent
travailler qui savent que sans travail
on ne peut pas réussir à cela il faut
redonner l'espoir et des moyens concrets
de retrouver un emploi sur la base à la
fois des droits et des devoirs droit à
une indemnisation évidemment devoir
devoir de suivre une formation ou de
prendre les emplois qui correspondent à
vos aptitudes droit à l'apprentissage
qui est la meilleure voie pour que les
jeunes a un emploi c'est comme cela que
nous pouvons tenir la promesse de la
République qui est aussi la promesse du
travail je veux aller plus
loin ça veut dire être au côté de ceux
qui donnent du travail ce ne sont pas
les hommes et les femmes politiques qui
créent le travail ce sont les
entrepreneurs alors oui il faut être au
côté des entrepreneurs cela veut dire
les aider et leur faire confiance cela
veut dire également changer le
raisonnement et le fonctionnement d'une
certaine administration les
entrepreneurs rêveraient que
l'administration soit leur allié
elle est souvent vécue comme un
adversaire c'est à nous de changer cela
personne d'autre que nous ne le
fera c'est aussi préférer le dialogue
social de terrain dans l'entreprise
plutôt qu'au niveau national ù trop
souvent le jeu de rôle paralyse tout
mais attention le dialogue social dans
l'entreprise ça n'est pas faire rentrer
la CGT dans les petites entreprises qui
ont besoin de dialogue social et pas de
conflit
sociaux le coût du travail a baissé Lee
travail formé le marché du travail
également a changé voilà les demandes de
bon sens des entreprises je fais le
choix du travail en aidant les
entreprise et il y a aussi ceux et je
vous demande votre attention il y a
aussi ceux qui pensent que l'on peut
s'en sortir sans travailler je ne
mentirai pas à cela je dis que nous ne
sommes pas le bon choix pour eux vous
aider si vous voulez retrouver un emploi
oui vous laissez de côté dans la sistana
sans vous aider c'est non le R par
exemple c'est oui mais en face il faut
la contrepartie jusqu'à 10 he de travail
par semaine pour vous aider à retrouver
un
emploi et il y a enfin ceux qui ont
travaillé qui ne peuvent plus le faire
en raison de leur râge de leur handicap
ou de leur état de santé nous leur
devons la justice la France est parfois
généreuse à tort mais pas avec cela
enfants handicapés veuv sous le seuil de
pauvreté ils ne manifesteront jamais ne
crieront jamais assez fort à eux je dis
que nous ne confondons pas la solidarité
et la sistana je veux une droite
intraitable et dure avec les fraudeurs
et les tricheurs je ne veux pas d'une
droite qui soit dure avec les plus
fragiles c'est notre responsabilité
c'est notre honneur la valeur travail
elle s'adresse à tous elle parle à tous
en fait la preuve c'est le message que
j'ai choisi avec mes amis pour la
campagne des régionales en or ptecalais
Picardie au travail car la région ne
s'en sortira que le travail la jeunesse
s'en sortira que par le travail la
France s'en sortira que par le travail
alors républicain c'est à nous nous
mettre au travail au travail pour la
République et pour la
France